well we most definitely need a bit of
populism tonight as we see the
corruption and the lies of the
establishment metastasize on multiple
fronts we've got it all covered tonight
the truckers convoy bidens russia war
games and of course the bombshell that
landed on the democrats and their media
servants overnight new charging
information from the russia hoax special
counsel john durham
after all those years of sanctimonious
lectures about russian hacking and
election interference and undermining
our democracy it turns out it wasn't
russia russia russia it was clinton
clinton clinton
they were the ones who did the hacking
it was the clinton campaign including
the present national security adviser
and the man now leading democrats
election integrity efforts who illegally
meddled in an election it was you
hillary clinton and you jake sullivan
and you mark elias who undermined our
democracy can you believe these people
just listen to how they talk
his final target is democracy itself one
of the things that we were trying to
explain to the press was this isn't just
about hacking and leaking emails this is
about a larger information effort
by the russians you have a president who
rather than
reassuring the american public in
american democracy is trashing american
democracy
every day he's trashing american
democracy
but now we know thanks to these
documents the factual background
attached to a motion filed by special
counsel john durham as part of his
indictment against former clinton
campaign lawyer michael sussman that the
clinton campaign paid a tech firm to
quote mine internet data to establish an
inference and narrative
tying then candidate trump to russia
in durham's words this included quote
non-public and or proprietary internet
data what is mining non-public and
proprietary data mean it means hacking
it means spying and look at their
targets according to durham quote
internet traffic pertaining to one a
particular healthcare provider two trump
tower three donald trump central park
west apartment building and four the
executive office of the president of the
united states yes you heard that right
they hacked not just trump tower but the
white house after trump became president
they hacked the white house these people
who pose as defenders of democracy
how is that even possible that the
clinton campaign hacked the white house
well
because they're part of the
establishment they hired a firm that
already had a top secret contract with
the white house here's durham describing
the person the clinton campaign paid to
do their hacking he had come to access
and maintain dedicated servers for the
executive office of the president as
part of a sensitive arrangement whereby
provided domain name system resolution
services he and his associates exploited
this arrangement by mining the executive
office of the president's dns traffic
and other data for the purpose of
gathering derogatory information about
donald trump the president
just let all that sink in for a moment
there's a tech firm that maintains the
internet service supporting the
president of the united states
the guy who's the current national
security adviser jake sullivan who just
lost the election with hillary
gets his campaign lawyer mark elias to
hire that tech firm with the white house
contract to hack into the white house to
try and dig up dirt on the sitting
president in an effort to show that the
2016 election was stolen by russia
and that same guy jake sullivan is now
running around hyping up war with russia
how can we believe a word he says look
what he said in october 2016 when he was
working for hillary clinton this could
be the most direct link yet between
donald trump and moscow it raises even
more troubling questions in light of
russia's masterminding of hacking
efforts that are clearly intended to
hurt hillary clinton's campaign oh
troubling questions about russia's
masterminding of hacking efforts to hurt
the clinton campaign he bubbled when at
that exact moment he himself was
masterminding hacking efforts to hurt
the trump campaign
by making up stuff about russia
the utter shamelessness of it it's just
staggering
and now he's out there just this friday
going on about how russia is going to
invade ukraine on wednesday
who knows where this will end up legally
for jake sullivan but there is no
question none at all
that he should immediately step down as
national security advisor
and then look at his boss hillary she's
now plotting another white house run
because it went so well the first time
look at what she said about all this
back in october 2016 computer scientists
have apparently uncovered a covert
server linking the trump organization to
a russian-based bank oh apparently
apparently computer scientists uncovered
my god have you ever heard such
dishonest
disingenuous poppycock
you hired the computer scientist you
lying wretch you hired them to make it
all up
you spied on your rival then when you
lost you hacked the white house
to try and prove your big lie that the
2016 election was stolen by russia you
made it all up so then you could run
around for years saying this
trump knows he's an illegitimate
president
and then you got all your democrat
cronies to spout your big lie
he lost the election and he was put into
office because the russians interfere so
do you believe president trump is an
illegitimate president
based on what i just said which i can't
retract he's an illegitimate president
in my mind folks look i absolutely agree
and of course hillary's criminal scheme
to undermine our democracy was cheered
on all the way by her servants in the
media let's just start with this one in
all its delicious humiliating entirety
the biggest scandal was when they spied
on my campaign they spied on my career
there's no real evidence of that of
course there is it's all over the place
leslie they spied on my campaign and
they got caught can i say something
you know this is 60 minutes
and we can't put on things we can't
verify it on because it's bad for
abiding we can't put on things we can't
verify leslie they spied on my campaign
well we can't very well i'm totally
verified no
no no this is 16 minutes leslie starr 60
minutes what a joke
she's not a journalist she's an
establishment propagandist they all are
bogus claims of spying on the
president's campaign trump's spy claims
debunked conspiracy theory people come
to cunanan through things like 911
trutherism the barack obama birth
certificate conspiracy theory the trump
spy gate stuff
and now today when their entire
narrative collapses and the whole world
can see that what they've been saying is
literally the opposite of the truth that
it was hillary who did the hacking that
it was hillary who did the russian
interference how did the media cover it
on the sunday shows today george
stephanopoulos abc
zero minutes
margaret brennan cbs zero minutes jake
tapper cnn zero minutes poor old chuck
todd he was bumped by the beijing
olympics nbc gotta keep that genocide
cash coming in but how much time do you
think he would have spent telling his
audience today that everything he's been
telling him about russia and the 2016
election for the last five years was a
lie
new york times nothing washington post
nothing reuters ap nothing nothing
nothing they are so embarrassed they
can't even begin to admit how wrong they
were
but honestly how can we have
a functioning democratic republic
when the media just buries information
that contradicts its ideological
narrative biden family corruption the
origins of the pandemic in the wuhan lab
the johns hopkins study showing
lockdowns didn't work and now this
america's establishment is rotten to the
core and that's why we need to keep
fighting for the positive populist
revolution
let us know what you think at steve
hilton excellent nexter of fnc and
shared this message hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else